-The GOP and Fox News are lying
about the state
of the economy under Joe Biden
and attempting to purge
from their ranks anyone
who dared vote for a bipartisan
infrastructure bill.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
There is a fundamental asymmetry
between the left and the right,
which is that one side is,
for all its many flaws,
at least interested
in attempting
to govern competently.
The other side, meanwhile,
has been captured
by a cult-like movement filled
with authoritarian weirdos
and cartoon gangsters
who always look like
they've either been chugging
white wine spritzers
[ Laughter ]
after everyone turns on them
at a "Real Housewives" reunion
or they just got hit
in the balls
[ Laughter ]
with a swinging paint can
by Kevin McCallister.
Although, in fairness,
Rudy usually looks more like
he's just realized he's been
left home alone by his parents.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Giuliani ]
Oh, no. How am I going
to take care of myself?
I'm only 800 years old.
[ Laughter ]
For example, there's been
a global climate summit
in Glasgow, where world leaders
have been gathering
to tackle the existential threat
posed by climate change.
And one of the major speakers
was former President Obama
and, before he got
to the serious stuff,
he, once again, started out
with some of his trademark
stand-up comedy material.
-I am a private citizen now,
so trips like this feel a little
bit different than they used to.
I don't get invited
to the big group photo.
Traffic is a thing again.
[ Laughter ]
Music doesn't play when I walk
into the room.
[ Laughter ]
On the positive side,
I can give a speech like this
without wearing a tie
and not create a scandal
back home.
[ Laughter ]
-Now that's what you'd think,
but Fox News is going to go
wall-to-wall with coverage
of your open collar
and a headline like...
[ Laughter ]
or...
But, more importantly, man,
this guy always
has new comedy material.
Now he's doing bits about what
it's like being out of office.
I don't know
how relatable it is, though.
[ As Obama ]
You know that thing where,
one day,
you're the most powerful man
in the world
and, the next day, your, uh,
wife is counting your Allman's?
[ Laughter ]
"No!"
But, after he was done testing
out new stand-up material,
Obama talked about the
responsibility of rich nations
and rich people to take the lead
in solving the climate crisis,
so that the burden of switching
to renewable energy
doesn't fall disproportionately
on the poor and working-class.
-A country like the U.S.,
with a higher
per capita carbon footprint
does have to do more
than a country
like Mali or Bangladesh.
It's also why we need
to make sure
the people most affected by the
transition to clean energy
aren't the ones bearing most
of the cost.
They don't have any margin
for error.
I can afford to give up a lot
of my current lifestyle
to benefit the planet
because I'll still have
a lot left over.
A lot of folks
don't have that cushion.
-He's right on both counts --
most people don't have
that cushion, but Obama does.
I mean, look at him.
Remember how he aged
like 20 years in office?
[ Laughter ]
Well, somehow,
he's aged backwards
[ Laughter ]
like 20 years,
after he left office.
It's like when a friend
who was in a miserable marriage
posts pics of herself on a beach
in Cozumel after her divorce.
"Damn, Janice!
[ Laughter ]
You look good!"
Obama looks like a hotshot
investor on "Succession,"
[ Laughter ]
who's threatening to take
control of the company.
In next week's episode,
he has to convince Cousin Greg
to come over to his side.
[ As Greg ]
Um, yeah, I'm, uh,
I'm pretty sure
that, uh, Logan told me not
to, uh, consort
[ Laughter and applause ]
with any ex-presidents or other
high-ranking luminaries,
or I could end up,
in his words, uh,
"pretty well [bleep]."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now, again, that's not to say
Democrats are doing enough
to tackle climate change
or that Obama couldn't have done
more when he was president.
He could've done more then
and Democrats could be
doing more now.
They still need
to get their massive
social spending bill
across the finish line
to invest in clean energy,
among many other things,
but, in addition to dealing
with obstructionists
in their own caucus,
who seem hell-bent
on protecting fossil fuels,
they're also up against a GOP
and right-wing media apparatus
filled with shameless liars
who have no interest
in doing anything at all
about the effects
of climate change.
For example, here's the
lieutenant governor of Texas,
explaining,
in the dumbest way possible,
[ Laughter ]
why he thinks wind
and solar power don't work.
-You cannot run America
on green energy.
We have to have thermal gas.
we have to have coal,
and we have to have nuclear.
We saw it in our freeze
last year in Texas.
We needed more thermal gas,
not more Green New Deal.
We were an example last year,
quite frankly, in the freeze,
that, when we needed
to rely on renewables,
they weren't there.
What happens if you go all-green
and destroy the oil
and gas industry;
and the coal industry
in Wyoming and West Virginia?
You can't rely on the wind
to always blow
or the sun to be out.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's not how it works,
you dingus.
[ Laughter ]
Did these people learn
about renewable energy
from a Hallmark card?
[ Laughter ]
Do these people genuinely not
realize that renewable energy,
just like any other form
of energy, can be stored?
Have they never heard
of batteries?
When your TV remote dies,
do you just jam
a lump of coal in there?
[ Laughter ]
Do they also think
you can't get electricity,
unless you catch it
with a key attached to a kite?
[ Laughter ]
"Honey, storm's coming!
I think we'll have
enough lightning
to watch an episode
of 'House Hunters'!"
[ Laughter ]
Also, none of what he said
about the Texas blackouts
is true.
The vast majority
of the power failure
during the winter blackout came
from fossil fuels.
And, of course, it wasn't
the Green New Deal's fault.
Obviously, most of the failures
came from coal and gas.
It's Texas.
The TV show "Dallas" was
about a family who was rich
from oil, not wind.
[ Laughter ]
When we finally found out
who shot J.R.,
it was his sister-in-law
Kristin,
not a windmill with a gun.
[ Laughter ]
Moving on.
I'm sorry, Wally,
is there a problem?
-Uh, could've used
a spoiler alert
before you ruined "Dallas"!
[ Laughter ]
-You are still going
to watch "Dallas,"
a show from 40 years ago?
-I am watching "Dallas."
I just finished Season 3
and you just ruined Season 4!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God! Next, you're going
to tell me you don't know
Henry Blake's plane
was shot down on "M-A-S-H."
-It was?!
[ Laughter ]
-I am so sorry about this bit,
everybody,
but the network suggested that,
since Taylor Swift was
on the show,
we should reference
the kind of television shows
that her fans watch,
like "Dallas" and "M-A-S-H."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You understand.
[ Cheering ]
They had heard the audience
would be full
of Loretta Switties.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, the point is,
these people are willingly --
So --
Anyway, the point is --
Guys, the point.
Can we please leave that
in the past?
[ Laughter ]
The point is
these people are willing
to lie so brazenly
and shamelessly about anything,
and that includes
the current economic situation.
There's no doubt
there are serious issues,
between inflation
and the supply chain crisis,
but, last night,
Fox host Laura Ingraham tried
to compare the economic
records of Trump and Biden,
in the most
deceptive way possible.
See if you can catch what's
misleading about this graphic.
-During Trump's presidency
and before the pandemic,
164,579,000 Americans
were working,
but, under Biden, a staggering
3,121,000 fewer
[ Laughing ] Americans are
in the workforce.
-Huh.
I can't get remember.
Did anything major happen
[ Laughter ]
between those two numbers?
I'm sorry if I'm a little foggy.
I was trapped in an attic
for a few months,
[ Laughter ]
wiping down doorknobs with Lysol
and hoarding the last scraps
of toilet paper
I could buy
off the black market,
while slowly descending
into a madness
so fully encompassing that,
for long stretches of time,
I could only hear
my own thoughts
in the voice
of MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Lindell ]
Oh, darn it!
I forgot to buy milk
at the grocery store.
I better go back
before my wife realizes
all I bought was a six-pack of
da beers.
[ Laughter ]
Now, not only are Republicans
and Fox News lying
about the economy,
they're also
so fundamentally opposed
to addressing those issues,
or even having
a functioning government,
that they're now threatening
to purge
any Republicans from their ranks
who voted for Biden's
infrastructure bill.
Marjorie Taylor Greene
called them traitors
and former Trump
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows said
they should be stripped
of their committee assignments.
Trump himself blasted
those Republicans in a speech
that he later released himself
in highlight reel form.
-I say it with a heavy heart.
No, thank you goes to those
in the House and Senate
who voted for the Democrats
non-infrastructure bill,
also known as the Democrat
presidential reelection bill.
It's only 11% was
infrastructure, by the way,
11% of that bill.
Much of it's
Green New Deal crap.
Just like throwing money
out the window.
But you gave Biden a victory,
as his poll numbers
were falling off a cliff.
[ Laughter ]
-Sorry, but you did have
four years
to pass an infrastructure bill
and you wasted it whining
about CNN's ratings
and drawing graffiti
on weather maps.
[ Laughter ]
That's a joke from our new
segment, "Remember That?"
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
When the president defaced
a weather map with a Sharpie
because he lied
about a hurricane?
[ Laughter ]
The only way it could've been
more obvious is
if he tagged it
with his initials.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "Remember That?"
♪♪
[ Cheering and laughter ]
[ Applause ]
But that's where we're at now --
keeping roads and bridges
from falling apart
is considered
giving Democrats a win,
instead of doing something
good for the country.
If Republicans had their way,
the Verrazzano Bridge
would just be an off-ramp
into the water
and New Yorkers would have
to get to Brooklyn
from Staten Island via kayak.
[ Laughter ]
[ Italian accent ] Oh!
What's with this freaking thing?
If it were any smaller,
I'd have to leave my balls
in the glove compartment.
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Also, Biden's numbers
were falling off a cliff?
Biden's numbers are
in the toilet, for sure,
but the only recent president
with worse numbers was you.
This is like if you walked
into the Jets locker room
and you heard them making fun
of the Jacksonville Jaguars.
That's right, everybody,
we are still doing Jets jokes
after they failed to win
back-to-back games.
And thank God.
It's the last
easy New York punch line
we have,
now that the Knicks got good,
LaGuardia's been renovated,
and de Blasio's leaving office.
Even the
Cigarette Smoking Cockroach
is using a nicotine patch now.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Raspy smoker's voice ]
It's not the same,
but it takes the edge off.
[ Laughter ]
The major divide
in our politics right now is
that one movement,
for its many flaws,
is actively interested
in doing things,
while the other is trying
to purge anyone
who participates in making
our government function,
and they lie shamelessly
about everything.
Whenever they open their mouths,
you can expect...
-The wind to always blow.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.